welcome to sniper ghost Warrior Three's
latest video gameplay walkthrough I'm
here to walk you through another mission
of sniper ghost Warrior 3 and it takes
place in the mountains of Georgia it is
covered in snow
and it's going to play and feel
completely differently to what we've
shown before in the mission
we're following a lead on a prisoner and
we're going to be infiltrating an enemy
outpost to try and rescue him
now we've already started choosing our
loadout we've taken our primary weapon a
sniper rifle and we've bought a bunch of
special bullets so now we're going to
take a secondary weapon an ak-47 out put
a silencer on it and grab a sidearm the
Garrett m9 also silenced we grabbed a
knife and go to the gadget section and
here the most important thing is the
drone which is going to be our best
recon tool we're going to modify it put
a hacking mod in it and it's going to
become very useful in this mission and
add some other modifications then we're
going to take a few throwing knives some
frag grenades and maybe a c4 explosive
and a decoy trap so once we've got that
we take on some armor and we're good to
go and do our mission
we will quickly confirm our selection in
the laptop and the screen on the left is
going to give us an idea of what we can
expect on this mission house it's in the
mountains we have no time to waste just
don't get yourself killed
in this video we're getting John through
another area controlled by the
separatists they push back the NATO back
to Georgian forces and taken over a
large part of the country including
military bases civilian towns comm
stations and industrial facilities they
have a lot of know-how on how to operate
the most high-tech facilities and John's
official task is to find out how they
can be operating at such a high capacity
and then to shut them down his
unofficial agenda though is to find his
brother Robert north
Robert was taken by unknown operatives
two years before and recent reports
indicate he was seen in this area of
Georgia and we're going to find out
what's happened to him and get him out
whether he wants to be helped remains to
be seen as nothing is ever simple in
these kind of scenarios okay
so we've arrived at the mission area and
normally snipers work in pairs with a
spotter who detects targets and measures
the distance and wind but John is deep
inside enemy territory without backup so
he has to act as his own spotter so the
first thing we'll do is find a good
vantage point and scout out the location
ahead
remember that higher ground is not
always the best place to be as you need
to have an exit route in case of an
alarm you don't want to be stuck in a
tower or under enemy fire with no way
out
watch out John the whole place is
monitored with CCTV maybe you should
focus on hacking their service first
good idea we've pretty much got the
whole location in view so it's time to
use the drone or recon the drone will
mark our enemies automatically and also
detect any traps such as mines it's
worth remembering that although this is
John's most high-tech tool it can and
will be noticed by the enemies so don't
fly it too close it can be modified
though to have more camouflage
capabilities and also features like
security camera hacking longer battery
life better tagging ranges so it's
important to gather resources around the
game world to afford these modifications
there's a CCTV box appearing on the
screen and Lydia who has both a
professional and personal history with
John has asked us to hack those boxes to
make infiltration easier
the drone also shows us sabotage objects
like generators and fuse boxes that we
can use to manipulate the AI when we're
done with recon it's time to take the
sniper rifle and take our first targets
now it's always a good idea to start
with the most isolated target
so this separatist right here in the
tower we're going to zoom in on him set
the scope to hundred meters to combat
bullet drop check the wind and pull the
trigger
in this mission we're about two-thirds
into the game and the place we are
attacking is pretty heavily guarded with
CCTV cameras armored enemies centuries
and towers and traps our task is to
rescue a prisoner from an abandoned
slaughterhouse which is now being used
for body disposal and interrogations the
prisoner is connected with Robert so
this is a high priority for John use
your mini-map and realize the
environment is your enemy
not only are there traps around the
outposts but there are deadly cliffs and
hungry wild animals but in this case the
environment can also be a resource and
if we trace these tracks we'll see a
safe path through the minefield in other
cases they may warn us of enemy
positions so a sniper going on his nest
might have a booby trap path to it just
to have his back secured also they can
tell us about mission specific clues
like if we're hunting for a target we
can look for his tracks and know where
he is
John is also a skilled demolitions
expert so he can disarm those mines and
can even get some resources out of it
when you look at this Georgian landscape
you can almost forget they're actually
regions torn apart by Civil War it's
time to get to a good sniping spot and
once again use the sniper rifle to take
out any enemies in the isolated
positions there's one on the rooftop and
always remember about the distance to
your target in the wind once you get a
clean shot pull the trigger after
neutralizing this enemy we have a clear
path for the drone to fly it to the CCTV
box and disable it like Lydia told us to
once we're close we will also be able to
tap into the feed and try and locate our
target these cameras are a good way of
gathering intel on your outpost even if
it's not directly specified in your
mission it's always a good idea to hack
them and see what's out there waiting
for you ok I hacked the CCTV server but
it seems there's another one controlling
the rest of the cameras
Lydia yes I know the location of our guy
is in one of the rooms in the basement
okay we have the location of our target
now we know he must be important to the
separatists because it's a very heavily
guarded outpost and we still have to get
to him so we're going to zip down and
see if we can find a path to the
basement always grab those resources
because they're going to be useful for
crafting later it's dark outside so
we'll be less visible to the patrolling
separatists but we'll have to stay out
of any lights on this level because then
we'll be easily spotted there's a lone
enemy in an isolated position so we're
going to try to sneak up on him and
interrogate him maybe he has something
useful for us how do I get to the
basement
Kieko I don't have it but my partner
always leaves his on the table depending
on the mission parameters these enemies
might give us different information so
in this case we got the information on a
key card that will allow us access to
the basement but due to the open nature
of most of the missions in sniper ghost
Warrior 3 we do not have to follow that
path
[Music]
there's still some enemies between us
and the keycards so we'll try to lure
some of these out with this generator
we'll turn it off they have someone come
and investigate and we'll set down an
ambush for it well hide his body just to
avoid detection in case somebody else
comes these separatist guards aren't
stupid so when one of them came to check
out the generator and this didn't get
the power back on somebody else will
come and try to fix it so we'll leave
this guy to fix the generator and take
care of them later
so now we're sure no one else will come
to investigate the generator but it's
still a good practice to hide the bodies
especially as this is in a highly
illuminated area and the light levels
are actually what guides any perception
in this game there's a camera noticing
us and we've already hacked onto one of
the other CCTV boxes but there's also a
second one controlling the other cameras
and we're going to take care of that now
once we're in we can cycle through the
feeds to make sure we haven't missed any
enemies and maybe get a better view of
the keycard there's the card and like I
said earlier we don't have to actually
get it but this is something that will
get you into the basement where the
prisoner is undetected and that's really
important in terms of an exit strategy
because once you're in you have to get
out and it's not going to be easy with
an entire outpost of enemies waiting for
you but if this is how you want to play
you can plant explosives or use a
grenade to blow the door to the basement
okay I found the key card so with a key
card all we need now to do is to find a
way in and release the prisoner we've
actually disabled all the cameras and
taken out a lot of the enemies on this
outpost but there's still a lot of
patrolling guards
this one in particular is a heavy enemy
and you can tell by the amount of bars
on his tag and the only way to take him
out in one shot would be a precise shot
to the back of the head or the eye and
as you've observed this is actually day
now so we're going to try and get out of
the open ground and when looking for a
path we're going to use the locations
verticality to our advantage so we're
going to climb the roof and see if we
can find a good entrance that's not
heavily guarded so here we have one
enemy and John is skilled to take out
his enemies quickly and slightly from
any position so we can drop down on them
and take them out so once again we're
going to hide the body and make sure
nobody finds it
here's one of the targets off our
most-wanted list who have committed the
most horrendous crimes against the
Georgian people whenever we find them we
can take them out to gain additional
rewards we have the key card so we can
quietly enter the basement I'm in the
basement
jon's close combat training allows us to
use chain kills when we see two or more
enemies close to each other I wish you
would slice the wine always gone
[Music]
sometimes we'll find captured civilians
in the game and we can help them if
we're able to please help us get us out
of here no promises but I'll see what I
can do
thank you sir don't forget about us we
can use scout mode to look for solutions
in this case it's going to be really
easy to shoot this lock pad to free the
civilians look for things to calm down a
little and then run for your lives
thank you anytime we provide help like
that we're actually helping the Rocky
Lions a resistance movement fighting
against the separatists and maybe
they'll help us in return
[Music]
John
why what did they do to you okay so we
found the prisoner but we're going to
have to cut the mission here to avoid
major spoilers thanks for watching this
video on sniper ghost Warrior 3 Mundia
no possible defeats me though below the
jaw yo believers is why
Oh
[Music]